[Music]
nobody has everything and nobody has
everything at every moment so it's about
listening
most people that want to give to
somebody that has everything wants to
give on their terms the reason I win is
because I listen and I give to people
what they need giving what you want that
person to take from you isn't giving
it's manipulating what you selfishly
want from that person so the answer to
your question is you got to [ __ ]
listen just you're not going to convince
them you know especially if you're
asking for money done what you've done
right you just gotta ask does that ask
154 people on LinkedIn and three will
say yes audience laughs like super
active on social it was like too much
and it's just like I got a bunch of [ __ ]
to do I don't know what it is to do you
know what I mean like I don't know it's
like I'll think like oh yeah podcast
people it's like I really know that's
our
like facebooking and spread and really
Facebook the big key is the volume of
content watch what I do not what I say
yeah got it literally looks a week I go
to my LinkedIn I click on yours as
scroll down what is doing lotteries
doing oh god that is how you will get
the answers it's kind of like push-ups
or like eating right like I'm giving it
to you it just not that easy to eat
really well and [ __ ] work out every
night you know what I mean
which is why it really starts here
because the biggest thing you have to
figure out is you're gonna be in [ __ ]
patient zone for the next two years
[Music]
I appreciate that
we help other businesses grow I highly
recommend there's a big fear of mine
that so many people see me make that
transition and don't realize that it was
15 years so I'm just saying that if
you're only two years into this and
you're gonna save lives even though you
may have that ambition I understand how
sexy it is do it first like and I would
say like minimum ly like put an
eight-year cap on like like those words
never came out of my mouth for 15 years
does that make sense health care so it's
a little bit I get it but the second
you're thinking about that part you're
vulnerable in your first part every
second I built Wine Library there was
never part of me that thought the
garyvee would exist those are
percentages built that will be your
leverage otherwise you're like every
other [ __ ] guy then [ __ ] build an
actual business and put 100,000 percent
into that and don't worry about the
consulting other businesses part which
is so seductive to the macro right now
[Music]
what would you say to win on Amazon and
Shopify that's the reverse of what
people don't understand I'm thinking
beyond the way to break into Bed Bath &
Beyond is to show them you want on
Amazon yes everybody has it reversed
that's why I always win everybody always
has it reversed
they let somebody else have the leverage
I never do my friend sent me here I'm
actually not
along the gambler I tried to get out of
that situation I did poorly in high
school because of my parents right so
I'm trying to start off my life if you
say I did poorly in high school because
of my parents
there's something interesting you may in
hindsight and years to come when you get
older see it as a huge advantage when I
hear stories of that much adversity the
amount of people that I know that I've
gone on to shine first of all for you to
be this young and have the aspirations
to break through instead of dwell and be
like I got [ __ ] it's over huge I think
if you keep building on that and like I
actually think being bad at high school
is foundationally a core reason most
people end up being successful and so
the more you start thinking about your
adversities as strengths the more the
reality of what you're trying to achieve
is gonna happen
keep going all right I'm trying to okay
I can't get into college I really want
to get into college right why so I can
get a degree to to get a job so I can
like have there's a really good chance
that that's not what is gonna happen
first of all you're gonna collect again
you're gonna go to college collect debt
and I'll let you go to a top 5% school
the jobs that are available to you on
the back end of that our garbage
[Music]
so aggressive
start having a basement I think the
biggest thing that a kid with this much
hard luck needs to think about it's
similar to two kids you're looking at
right now which is can you attach
yourself to a good situation where you
pay your dues to build a foundation if
I'm you I try to get it attached to a
top 5,000 entrepreneur you already
[ __ ] ate dirt because of your family
situation
eat dirt for three more years being
somebody's assistant get into the
ecosystem of real [ __ ] college of
entrepreneurship which is being close to
somebody who's doing it your biggest
advantage is that you're willing to live
like [ __ ] which means you don't need a
lot of money which means you can work
for basically for dick for somebody
who's really done it and if she or he
sees that you've got it you'll win
that's the biggest [ __ ] piece advice I
could give to a kid that's got a [ __ ]
situation how do I get out of analysis
because I would
just go just do it you're about you're
valuing other people's opinions my
question is why do you look so sharp do
you love it or do you think it's reject
something to other people you got a
break you got to figure that out the
only reason people overthink is thing
cuz they worry about the judge me I go
fast because I don't give a [ __ ] for
real like for [ __ ] real what am I
going fast but only one things that I'm
just really really knowing grass and you
should do it and if you don't know it
hedge it upfront you can start a video
it's like I'm not sure the [ __ ] I'm
talking about
Wow thank you so much doing the game if
you're not doing nothing's happening
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you guys are trying to get people into
your program
okay well the keys you can target on
Facebook and Instagram for such low
money it doesn't matter what I'm gonna
tell you right now you need to try
everything at 25 bucks apiece until you
find something everybody does the body
[ __ ] yeah so that's already a problem
but this is what creativity matters it's
the reason you're wearing this jacket
everybody wants to sell you a jacket so
maybe maybe it's one big picture of an
arm flap one big picture I haven't seen
that as much and what if that woman
really [ __ ] hates her arms
everybody's doing the same [ __ ] look how
good I look you can be like me that's
what every [ __ ] person does which
means it's hitting nobody like even this
I like better already because at least
it's different and it probably didn't do
as well in life but that's not what
matters when you're trying to sell
something like like well lights don't
matter cause you try to sell program you
don't [ __ ] like this dudes like this
I know I'm right now I'm trying to get
you hyped enough to [ __ ] do what you
need to do I would put out a post of
both you talk and say we would like to
speak to 400 women who are not happy
with their health situation do you miss
your phone number we will call you then
you take [ __ ] a month and listen and
then you figure out what to make content
hey guys thank you so much for watching
my video on YouTube I wanted to jump in
here at the end because I'm working on a
ridiculously important project for me
and I have a funny feeling you can help
if you drink wine at all or know anybody
that drinks wine at all please go to
empathy wines calm right now and sign up
for a subscription whether it's a three
pack whether it's a six pack or whether
it's a whole case of each for the year
if you drink thirty six bottles of wine
a year or give away thirty six bottles
of wine a year please sign up for Club
empathy this project means the world to
me that could really use your support
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]